pediatrician's office is inundated with
sick kids battling flu croup rsv and
covet in today's pointers from a
pediatrician segment dr keri weijie
singha the medical director and founder
of siena pediatrics in henderson spells
out the impact this most recent variant
of covet is having on kids she's
treating
this wave of omicron we're definitely
seeing more children being affected this
is actually like a flu season for
pediatricians now we're seeing a range
of symptoms the biggest change was croup
you know we normally would talk about
proof which is a viral infection infects
the throat and you can have a seal or a
basically a dog bark noise and um
omicron was added to the list of viruses
uh you know or variants to covet coming
in to give children crews this is
actually one of the ones why you want to
bring your children to the office we can
do something especially below two years
of age
to give either oral prescribe oral
steroids or even maybe do an injection
of oral or injection of steroids too
so that's number one uh we're seeing
even in the last week or two the other
thing is children are having fever
they're having cough runny nose it can
be a cold it can appear like a flu-like
illness too that is a little different
than what we saw before we saw a lot of
the dry coughs we saw a loss of taste
and smell
but this one's kind of a heartier
variant with children
i will tell you fortunately we have not
had to have any children hospitalized in
the last couple weeks there are reports
out there where having children in the
u.s being hospitalized as a parent
you're at home so your kids come down
with certain
circumstances at what point do you want
to see kids in your office i bet you're
inundated with everything and how do you
prioritize what message you want to get
out there to parents um so basically
that's a great way prioritizing children
with symptoms so just like the ones i
just mentioned those should have the
children in the office to get seen and
and the other thing is also remember
there are other things flu is starting
to increase and so a lot of
pediatricians are going to test for the
flu and they're going to test for covid
we saw a very large number of rc
children in the last six months so we're
still seeing some as well there is just
the common colds of course but we're
seeing a lot of bacterial infections
from the initial viral infections like
ear infections even some pneumonias so
those are the children with those
symptoms we want to see if you have a
family member that tests positive it is
highly transmissible like we are being
told and we're seeing but you may not
have symptoms yet it is better for you
not to bring your child into the
pediatrician's office at that point
wait and see if there is actually
symptoms too um
as we're all fully aware we're having
health care workers get this despite our
proper attire and so we're trying to
minimize the risk to our um health care
workers too as much as possible so
please come into your pediatrician's
office if you have symptoms um also bear
with us we are dealing with a shortage
of rapid tests my office is getting a
bunch later to date or tomorrow but we
were down a day and we were able to do
pcrs but that takes a couple days
dr reje singha adds that medical
professionals are also seeing higher
cases of covet in the very young age
range because no vaccine has been
approved yet for the two to
five-year-olds she says during vaccine
trials that age range didn't create
antibodies as high as expected and more
research is needed